>> SHE'S A WONDERFUL PERSON.
SHE'S BEEN THROUGH HELL.
THEY PUT THIS YOUNG WOMAN
THROUGH HELL.
WHAT SHE HAS HAD TO PAY FOR
LEGAL FEES AND EVERYTHING ELSE,
I LET EVERYBODY TESTIFY.
I WANTED TO BE TOTALLY OPEN
BECAUSE I KNEW THERE WAS NOTHING
THERE.
THERE WAS NOTHING THERE.
NOTHING AT ALL.
>> Laura: PRESIDENT TRUMP
VEHEMENTLY DEFENDING HOPE HICKS
JUST A SHORT TIME AGO, THE
LONGTIME TRUMP EMPLOYEE AND
CONFIDANT OF SENIOR
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
MENTIONED IN THE MUELLER REPORT
TO TESTIFY BEFORE CONGRESS.
AS EXPECTED, THE DEMOCRATS ON
THE HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
DIDN'T GET A LOT OF ANSWERS FROM
HER, WHICH, OF COURSE, THEY
CLAIMED AS A CONSPIRACY BY THE
PRESIDENT.
WE SHOULD NOTE HICKS IS NOW
EXECUTIVE VP, CHIEF OF
COMMUNICATION FOR FOX
CORPORATION.
JOINING ME NOW, ALAN DERSHOWITZ,
HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR EMERITUS,
AND ALSO WROTE ABOUT THE MUELLER
REPORT.
SOME SAY HICKS' REFUSAL TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS PUSHES THEM
FURTHER DOWN THE PATH TOWARDS
IMPEACHMENT.
WHAT SAY YOU?
>> WELL, FIRST, ONE BRIEF REMARK
ABOUT YOUR PRIOR SEGMENT.
ANYBODY WHO EVER COMPARES WITH
GOING ON AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER
TO "NEVER AGAIN" ARE
CONCENTRATION CAMPS IS
ENCOURAGING HOLOCAUST DENIAL.
BECAUSE WHAT THEY ARE SAYING IS
IF ALL OF THAT HAPPENS TO THE
JEWS IN NAZI GERMANY AND POLAND
IS HAPPENING AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER AND THERE ARE NO DEATH
CAMPS, NO KILLING SQUADS, NO
FINAL SOLUTION.
SO SHAME ON THEM FOR BEING
HOLOCAUST DENIERS.
AS FAR AS THE CURRENT ISSUE IS
CONCERNED, ALL THREE BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT HAVE PRIVILEGE.
YOU CAN'T CALL A LAW CLERK AT
THE SUPREME COURT AND ASK WHAT
WAS DISCUSSED WITH THE JUSTICE.
IT IMAGINE IF THEY TRIED TO PULL
LEGISLATIVE ASSISTANCE OF
CONGRESSMEN, THEY WOULD BE UP IN
ARMS.
EACH BRANCH OF THE GOVERNMENT
HAS A FORM OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
AND THE PRESIDENT IS PERFECTLY
ENTITLED TO INVOKE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
LET THE COURTS DECIDE IF THEY
THINK IT GOES TOO FAR, BUT THE
DANGER AS YOU CAN DIMINISH
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE AND
LEGISLATIVE PRIVILEGE AND
JUDICIAL PRIVILEGE, NOT ONLY FOR
THIS ADMINISTRATION, BUT FOR
FUTURE ADMINISTRATIONS.
A BIG STRUCTURAL IMPACT ON
GOVERNMENT AND CIVIL LIBERTIES.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMEN WAS ON
ANOTHER NETWORK TONIGHT, AND HE
BASICALLY IS SAYING LOOK, THIS
IS RIDICULOUS, TRUMP IS NOT A
MONARCH.
THAT IS A REAL CONSTITUTIONAL
ARGUMENT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WE DON'T HAVE A KING, THERE
IS NO SUCH THING AS ABSOLUTE
IMMUNITY.
SHE DIDN'T INVOKE ANY PRIVILEGE,
THEY JUST USED A MADE UP CLAIM
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS, WHICH WILL BE
REJECTED AGAIN BY A COURT.
>> Laura: THE DEBATE HERE IS
RIDICULOUS.
GO AHEAD.
>> THESE CONGRESSMEN ALWAYS
ARGUE THE PRESIDENT IS NOT ABOVE
THE LAW AND THEY PUT THEMSELVES
ABOVE THE LAW, THEY TRIED TO GET
PEOPLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THAT
ARE NOT SUBJECT APPROPRIATELY TO
BEING ASKED.
THEY WANT TO IMPEACH WITHOUT THE
CRITERIA FOR IMPEACHMENT BEING
SATISFIED.
CONGRESS IS NOT ABOVE THE LAW.
THE PRESIDENT ACTS WITHIN
ARTICLE TWO OF THE CONSTITUTION.
IF THAT IS NOT ABOVE THE LAW.
CONGRESSMEN AND SENATORS CAN'T
BE PROSECUTED FOR WHAT THEY SAY
ON THE FLOOR OF CONGRESS.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THEY ARE ABOVE
THE LAW -- THAT IS THE LAW.
BUT THERE ARE DIFFERENT LAWS
REGULATING PRESIDENTS,
CONGRESSMEN, AND MEMBERS OF THE
JUDICIARY.
THEY ALL HAVE FORMS OF IMMUNITY
THAT DON'T PUT THEM ABOVE THE
LAW, THAT IS WHAT THE LAW
PROVIDES.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE IT, CHANGE THE
LAW.
>> Laura: THEY SAY THERE IS NO
ABSOLUTE IMMUNITY FROM
TESTIMONY.
THERE IS NO ABSOLUTE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
BUT CONVERSATIONS BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS WITH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, I THINK GOING
BACK TO THE CLINTON
ADMINISTRATION, THE OLC OPINION,
IT WAS TWEETED EARLIER TONIGHT,
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR.
THIS IS CLASSIC EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE INFORMATION.
CLASSIC.
>> FIRST, IT IS, NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, PRESIDENTS OFTEN
INVOKE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE AND
LEAVE IT TO THE COURTS BEAR THAT
IS WHERE THE SYSTEM OF CHECKS
AND BALANCES IS ABOUT.
CONGRESS SEEKS INFORMATION, THE
PRESIDENT SAYS NO, AND THE
COURTS DECIDE GET THE SYSTEM
WORKS AND WHAT HAPPENS.
NO PRESIDENT WAS EVER -- WHEN
THE COURTS TOLD NIXON TO TURN
OVER THE TAPES, HE DID.
CLINTON HAD TO MAKE CERTAIN
INFORMATION, AND HE DID.
CONGRESS HAS THE POWER TO GO TO
THE COURTS, BUT THEY SHOULDN'T
BE COMPLAINING ABOUT PRIVILEGE
BECAUSE THEY WOULD DO IT